hello and welcome to this special Street
Fighter 5 breakdown we have three people
who have been playing the game
we have Peter Brown hello hello yo the
same Erte top so all three of you have
been playing street fight fight for
about four hours each right around that
time yes yeah okay so you've been
playing this game a lot so I guess if we
use Street v 4 as a reference point how
different is it first of all from Street
beaufort it's kind of septa because a
lot of the footage we've seen it is
reminiscent of the same visual style
that we've seen before
yeah but the mechanics have totally
changed in a lot of ways I mean you
still have a lot of the same super
attacks he always had but it's they've
gotten rid of the focus attack which is
a big deal they replace it with a bunch
of new systems some of which take
inspiration from alpha and from the
third strike as well yeah I think that's
the most interesting part of of 3 5 5 is
they made a very conscious effort to
make the game feel as diverse as
possible in all aspects so the character
roster is is plugging plugging
characters from all across the games
like it's got third strikeout Aires Rome
it's got three four four characters so
it's I imagine in the future they're
gonna pick up more characters from
across the series sure and at the same
time it's like the mechanics are very
from player to play all right
yeah I feel like the mechanics it's like
building upon systems of their previous
games and kind of picking some of the
better ones and then trying to mix mash
that into five and I think just from the
little that we played they've done a
good job I think it's interesting it's
kind of like you know you have v-trigger
now which is like a new attribute skill
in the game that like almost reminds me
a little bit of killer instinct it like
instinct mode it kind of separates the
characters and gives like each character
a special kind of thing that they do
that then other characters don't do but
you know mechanically it's still Street
Fighter so anyone that's played Street
Fighter will still like Street Fighter
II good game yes adding these nice
little layers on top I'll be completely
honest honest with you what when I first
saw the the first trailer of Street by 5
I was a little bit because it was Ryu
and it was channeling it was similar
setting and
I didn't think it was different enough
so you've been playing with and bison
and Charlie as well do you think it's
different enough do you think they're
going far enough it's impressive how
quickly they've arrayed on what we've
seen you know what we saw first and wait
wait it is now like visually if you go
back and look at the first to reveal
trailer it looks incredibly different
than what we played I remember going
when I was playing it and recording
footage of it I stopped at various
points like Marvel that some of the the
actual animations they look really good
like when we used engine stuff and the
Perry stuff that he's got looks super
impressive I think it's you think it's
very different like Charlie for example
you know under a child character and
gnash sorry
he's no longer a child character and
that's a conscious effort to make him
different from maybe a guy who appears
yeah it's another child character even
even bison for example he doesn't have
all the classic charge moves they're
kind of varied in in a lot of ways yeah
and you know you're talking about V
triggers but V scales are another thing
that actually differentiates every
character and pretty major ways speaking
about Charlie one thing he can do and
and this is replacing the focus attack
so the v-skill little punch middle kick
together it takes no meter and what you
can do with Charlie is actually grab a
fireball and put in your pocket yeah
I've seen that he just grabs it just
throws it took so easy yeah the Philip
is meter which is ingenious that's great
and you know cuz fireball is projectiles
those are one things that create the
distance game for a lot of players and
there seems to be an answer for pretty
much every character like m.bison now
can reflect a projectile back and it's
really quick yeah the way he does it
yeah thanks designed to like to around
the character you want to be playing
bison it seems like with bison
specifically they have a very specific
style of play they want from him like
for him to be a kind of like aggressive
like we even when you game on the back
foot he's always liable to like rush
back and that kind of reflects followed
by like a scissor kick or get someone
back in the corner and at the same time
for example the the his standing hard
kick from Street Fighter 4 is gone which
means you have to be a lot smaller about
the way you apply a pressure you can't
just BAM hard kick over and over again
so it's like that kind those kind of
tweaks and changes and really like fall
out design and decision
already what's exciting about the game
right yeah I think the skill is awesome
I also think it's gonna be like one of
the hardest things for them to balance
because yeah every character has a
different one right and like let's take
rise for example he has a parry which is
very reminiscent to the third strike but
at least currently nobody else has a
parry so do high-level players get
really good with Perry and is that more
dominant than some of the other V skills
I don't know but actually that's gonna
be a read the fool balancing act right
because everyone's familiar with
powering how it works and in in the
competitive scene like you know are we
gonna be used to what the other
characters skills are and are they gonna
be as effective right what's good those
there are also V reversals which is a
meter based move that isn't exactly a
parry but it's sort of you know as you
take damage you build up your your V
gauge and this revenge move essentially
once you've been hit enough you can you
know take a tacit that's come at you and
just basically get get rid of it yeah
you can trigger it so I'm not do any
damage so it's not exactly a perry wrote
it nullifies damage and every character
has that ability yeah so it's just like
a mixture between the alpha colors from
alpha and the push block from Marvel vs.
Capcom yeah and in a lot of ways says
that there's a lot of lessons they've
learned from all of us at Capcom like
for example V trigger feels almost like
an x-factor style comeback mechanic but
they've also thought about because a lot
of the questions they had was x-factor
was too powerful like people could turn
it around and it was completely broken
and so it looks like they've thought
about like the benefits of having that
combat mechanic for people who might you
know not be as skilled as other players
but also balanced it with an element of
execution and strategy and that kind of
thing so it's kind of like the best of
both worlds which is good for people who
you know who are dedicated to the game
in the long run and how do you think the
game looks I mean bison he's got white
hair now he looks even more evil his
trench coat is amazing I mean what do
you think of the designs of the
characters yeah I mean again it's very
similar to four in a lot of ways or are
those small touches that are different
one thing that actually stood out to me
a negative light and I realized because
the game is still early that this will
probably change but the the background
elements were really poorly animated
you know I can't imagine them shipping
the game like in this state because it's
very choppy he didn't seem like the
characters were transitioning from you
know their different movements like
they're so comical and fun to watch but
there's that level of Polish that's
missing mmm I'm sure that'll be fixed
yeah it does seem like there's elements
of it and like I said from not to
apologize or make excuses for them like
but like if you look at the kind of the
iterations they're doing it seems like
they're focusing along what people are
directly looking right and already
focusing their main characters like the
lighting stuff is really impressive so I
imagine I hope that by the time we get
the final game it'll be a little better
animate the stuff in the background but
yeah so I mean distrito fog was
announced at the end of last year and it
was an exclusivity deal with Sony mm-hmm
do we honestly think that the
PlayStation 4 is gonna be the only
console you can play this or do you
think future versions are going to come
out on the Xbox one
oh no way Sony is funding it right I
have a new scoop for you is exactly what
you think is I put I put it to the
Telegraph speaking to the Capcom mocking
guy and I said will there be another
version of this game because the cynical
amongst us are saying Ultra Street
Fighter 5 for Xbox one and Capcom the
representative said outright there will
never be a 3 for 5 on anything but
PlayStation don't you see and NPC never
never never ever he was he was like
never ever ever ever ever knows that all
right well and on that bombshell for
more news and analysis and videos on
Street Fighter 5 stay tuned to game spot
you